Florida is investigating a major new
concern in the fight against the Zika
virus the first possible Zika infection
by a mosquito here in the United States
officials say that the patient did not
travel to a region with a known outbreak
the virus has been spreading north for
dozens dozens of states report having
Zika patients but the Miami case could
be the first local transmission our
chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook is in New York to bring us up to
date John this town scary what does it
mean exactly Gail this could be a big
deal and the way it would happen would
not be by mosquitoes flying up from
Latin America to the United States they
only travel about a half a mile on their
whole life who would be from a person
who was infected say in Brazil coming up
here to the United States now there
would still be virus in the person's
bloodstream then an uninfected mosquito
in the United States would bite that
person become infected and then turn
around and bite an uninfected person and
now you would have local transmission
this isn't this exactly what the CDC was
worried about that this could then mean
Nate more many more transitions
transmissions rather here in the United
States that's exactly right Nora and I
should say that we have learned that
sexual transmission has not been ruled
out yet so there's going to be some
further testing that goes on in the next
couple of days and it's expected by
Friday that possibility will be
established one way or another in
Florida what are they saying to pregnant
women well pregnant women it's the same
advice and and the best advice really
charlie is you go to the CDC website and
you look under Zika pregnancy in this
very specific advice that's changing a
little bit it seems like every few weeks
but basically it's to cover up make sure
that you use insect repellent rye to
stay indoors air conditioning things
like that but the big next step here and
in the next couple days is going to be
to look at local mosquitoes which
they're already doing to see if the
local mosquitoes in Miami have the Zika
virus in it and also to test people in
the neighborhood and see if somehow
they've become infected because remember
eighty percent of people who get
infected have no symptoms so it might
already have started to spread by local
mosquitoes without people knowing it so
John why are they publishing it if
they're not exactly sure that it is eco
yeah how quickly doesn't spread yeah I
worry I wondered about the same exact
thing and I spoke to a representative of
the Florida State Health Department
yesterday and she said look the reason
why they're even telling us without all
the information there with some
asterisks is that starting now and in
the next few days they're going
door-to-door they're going to be
knocking on people's doors saying can we
take some blood to test you they're
going to be testing local mosquitoes and
it would have been weird that people
would have started asking questions so
they made this public announcement and
they're trying to get ahead of it and
telling people look let's just prepare
for the worst which would be local
spread and in that case all of the
precautions that we've told you about
all over a time time again they wanted
them to start doing now sooner rather
than later dr. Jon LaPook thank you so
much